en la actualidad contamos con dos chefs
que tenemos tres cocinas activadas
alrededor de puerto príncipe y de elekta
y esa es la parte sur donde realmente
está la situación más grave porque fue
el epicentro del terremoto y en
me encuentro en gaming que también es
parte de la región más afectadas en la
parte sur donde ya sabemos también estar
cocinando y bueno que llevamos 20 mil
aproximadamente alimentos que se han
servido desde el tiempo que llevamos
aquí
jari litmanen también nos contó cuáles
son los productos que más están
escaseando actualmente en haití y cuál
es el llamado que hacen como ong para
que la comunidad internacional y el
gobierno nacional así serán los
damnificados
pues en general en general está sea todo
porque el país no tiene un gran
inventario de alimentos y no es una
cuestión de ahora del terremoto es que
así es como funciona así que ya en dos o
tres días estamos viendo cómo hemos casi
consumido la capacidad de inventario que
tienen aquí en el padrón
especialmente en la parte de las
proteínas las carnes los refrigerados
así que ya estamos viendo cómo podemos
atraer o traer de diferentes partes de
miami eeuu
alimentos que puedan entonces
abastecernos para poder alimentar al
resto de la población